HIIIIIIII... NEIGHBOR, how ya doing? you just gonna keep being an asshole back there?
so what we need, is we need to solve this puzzle and I'm not exactly sure
but my interpretation of this is.... there's a house...and then there's another house with a funky attachment.
this could mean the middle of the street....is the starting point...
...and then you take left 8 steps, back 24, whatever the hell that means...and whatever the hell that means.
so if the- like that's the only interpretation that I can make from this.
it's not some metaphysical thing where the house is upside down.
that is literally my house and his house, right?
so you take 8 steps left, 24 steps back, that thing and that thing which looks like a lambda and a... magnet or something.
okay so that's what I'm gonna do, I'm gonna try that. so that must be what it is.
I..you know, I'm-I don't think I'm mistaken about that.
so if- ah see, cause that one's yellow... well I mean that one's not red... but i guess... okay whatever.
let's just assume that this is correct, so the midway point between these two houses...
go left *counts to eight*, back *counts to twenty-four*
well that kinda- oh!
*gasp* what is that?
i don't have any room in my inventory, I gotta throw a fucking appl-
NOOO! GOD DAMN IT! I was right there!
YOU ASS!
there was something over there.
STOP! I'm trying to be... GOD DAMN IT Now you're guarding it!
You sack of tits...
Okay, so... I go back here... There was something back there... Did I get rid of what I had in my hands? Probably..
Okay...Yeah. What is it? Is it a toilet? Toilet plunger?
Goddamnit! Again you sack of shit just STOP! Let me take look at it! Oh fucking stop...
You goopy bastard.
Oop- shi- aww fucking shit!
It's a magnet! It is a magnet! It's a MAGNET!
*gasp* I ca- ohhhhhhhhh!
I know! Oh I know! I know! I know I know I know!
I KNOW! I SOLVED SOMETHING! WITH MY BRAIN!!!!!!!!  Oh fucking shi-- How did I drop that?..Oh that's- that's not the magnet I don't know what that is..
OH, it's a bucket for water that he put over the door to try to... trap me, I-I guess.. like an idiot
OK whatever, but that doesn't matter, because I have- oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck. Just fucking, D000N'T D0 IT!! Asshole~!
so... HEH, HEH, that's not gonna work on ME- FUCK!!!
God damn it, he's gonna get me isn't he? Oh, he's gonna get me...oh, he's gonna get me
oh, wut the FUUUUUCK WAS THAT
OK, well, alright then...Okay but oh man, this is- this is difficult to get around this ASSHOLE
But I got what I needed and actually I'm gonna turn...I'm gonna turn that back on
Just so we can have some power in the goddamn house
And maybe...see everything
Uh oh.
Well that doesn't sound good...
Maybe I shouldn't have turned the power back on
Cause I think that's the security cameras checking me out  whoaaaah  fuck
QWOP
MISSED ME BITCH!
Now if I can just get past this thing...
So now that makes more sense
In the middle of the house, if you go left 8, back 4
Between the fences there's a magnet
I dunno why it's orange and blue, but,
It is what it is...ok
*Mark grunts and neighbor gasps* Fucking god damn it.
AGHHHHHHH
FUCK
I'm pretty sure I did it before by crawling out like this...
Oh, well he's gonna get me next time I fail
*Good job Mark* HEEEAAAAAHHHHH
AHHHH
HE NOT GET TO MEEE
HE NOT GET ME
HE NOT GET... Ha, dodged your jizz~
Okay you go back, you do your thing
I'm gonna do my thing
Which is... be smarter than you and not die and not suck
and also be cool
I mean that's a lot of things at once that I said, but it's all gonna happen, trust me.
I'm gonna turn off your power again because fuck you.
FAK you
Uh-oh, he's a-comin'. He's a-right-a-behind me... oh boy
Whelp, this isn't gonna lose him
Fucking goddamnit... What a bag of dicks
*Neighbor gasps* oH fuckin hello
Don't mind me as I slam my crotch into your face
You ever just try to vault over someone and just end up slamming your dick into their nose?
Kay, take tre--
AAAHHHH OOH fack
HWOP-- fuck
Fucking god damn it.
GODDAMNIT
Why is that fucking impossible?
Ah fucking GOD
* high pitched screaming*
FUCK YOU
YES!
Fucking hell...okay.
So, yes!
Just like that!
That's how that's supposed to go--FUCK THIS APPLE.
Alright, so now I now I got this
I got this; it's a key
In case you didn't--KNOOOOW
Okay
Got that
Now
With the flashlight back on he's stuck there FER-EH-VER
And now I go upstairs with free reign
*Strange accent* How can I do? I cannot see
I am point at key
Whoop
I am point
*Still strange accent* Unlock?
Undo?
It open now
Oooka- oh shitfuck
Okay...
Alright
Alright, close this door
He's still thumping bass line-
Whoa
The fuck is that?
What is that supposed to be?
What the hell is that?
Who built this house?
Who did any of this?
What the fuck?
Why is there a hole?
Ohhhhh okay
Well, the question is: do I wanna drop down there?
And I don't think-- I don't think I do
But I also think that maybe I should power on the hoooouse...?
*loud thumping*
Oookay sorry about that.
Didn't mean to do-*lightning^oooh
Sorry about that
Okay, you know what? I'm just gonna go down because what's the worst that could happen?
Hioop
Ah!
Ohhhh
OHHHHHHUOHHHH Okay gonna need throw this
Bleee
Now that got that outta the way
Lemme explore this room
There's a closet, there's another flashlight
Get this offa here
Hep-oied
Okay well that opened up...
That opened up some doors here
Ohhh, okay, that opened up this door and that means that opened
Woah
That, uh...
That doesn't seem right
I'm pretty sure that's some sorta inca-
Woahhh
What the fuck is that?
So where did this go?
Oohh
Kaayyyy...
That doesn't make a lot of sense
But I guess..I think I might have seen that
Hheeh  eeehh
I can't close it. It's too strong
I can't do it, I'm too wimp!
Okay, I really wish I could turn the power back on...
Welp, that's locked.
So, what's the point?
Okay, so what I need to do is I need to get the power back on...
I'm pretty sure that's a step
Not just this power, but I need to get the actual power in the house back on
Is he still stuck?
He is still stuck.
GOOD!
Maybe he should fucking STAY that way!
Okay, so power's back on in the house
He's still stuck
Good...
But I don't know how much longer he's gonna last like that-- (crashing sound)
HEY BUDDY!
Yeah, I'm just gonna keep exploring your house, don't mind me!
Ooh...
Right, well, turn that on. Eugh.
Alright, that's on.
So what does this do?
Does this do anything?!
WHOA!
OhhHHhhH
oHHHhhH
So, the question is...
Can I make it all the way over here...
To there in time?
Whoa, can I get up that goddamn couch?
Can I get on there? Thank you.
AH, FUCKING gODDAMMIT I GOT TRIPPED UP BY THIS GODDAMN LAMP
GET THE FUCK OUTTA MY WAY
I just need to get everything that COULD be in my way outta my way
And then I'll be okay.
If I'm on this side, I'm not gonna exactly make it.
Whew! Nope, not gonna make that, that's not gonna work
Maybe if I go backwards on it?
MAYBE IF I DAB ON 'EM!
Fuck.
So there's gotta be a way to get up there...
There's gotta be a way.
It's quick, but it ain't that quick.
Oh, maybe if I use the magnet!
Can I use the magnet to repel?
I can't FUCKIN' SEE ANYTHING, but maybe I can use the magnet to repel.
But either way, the power's on, so I need to see this.
So Boop!
Doosh!
Okay.
So can I use the magnet to push and pull that thing?
[High pitched] NOPE!
WHOA!
Whoa, I did it! I did it! I did it! I did--
Oh, I didn't do it.
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, I did not do that. Okay.
Well, I ALMOST did it.
So maybe just the timing's gotta be better.
AHHHHHHH!!
Fuck.
Okay, what happens if I throw this at it?
FUCKING NOT MY FLASHLIGHT!
eeehhhh
NOPE.
WHOA. DID IT! Okay, got it!
(can't unlock door) OH, COME ON!
I'm gonna get up here and you're gonna tell me that it's gonna be fucking locked???
The fuck are you doing with my life?
(accent) This fucking douche
Maybe I can get over there, there might be something over there
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH Fuck
There's a banana!
I got a banana
What do I d- woah
Okay  Ohhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
[British accent] I know what I could do with this ba-na-na
I could make him slip and faaall
That doesn't help me- is there anything over here that I could do..?
Naaaaaaw
Naaaw man
Man, there's a lot of agility puzzles in this
More than I would've thought
Anyway I got up there but I just
I can't open it
Yeah and there's
Ohh there's a top one
Oh I didn't even see that
Not that I could've gotten up there anyway
I guess if I'd have brought something up with me maybe
K lemme- lemme just as an experiment I'm-una
I'm gonna leave all my st- woah
Ffff- noooo~....
*deep inhale*
FUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUU
I just wanted to drop it somehow my fucking magnet got thrown into the abyss
Oh it's down there
Well at least I know where it fucken is
Alright, so what I'm gonna do is. I'm gonna bring
Boxes with me.
and I'm gonna try to get up there again.
so..I'm-una bring it down,
it's just a matter of timing,
ohhhh, yes, okay, easy peasy!
so I don't know if anything is actually up there,
But! maybe there is! woah..
Hey... if I!  if I,
am careful about this...
whoops! ...okay, not that careful. whoa!
Kay, not that- not that brash.
okay, that's not gonna work.
Heh, ok!
heh! nope! BAH!
Fuck it. Well, is there anything up there
that I need..Oh,
all I needed was One! Oh, all I needed
wa-Nice shoes that I got. but all I needed was one.
Really.
Ugh..It's gonna be tough. But I- I gotta imagine that's
why there's so many boxes here. I mean
that's gotta be it, right? Why else would they have all the boxes here?
So all I gotta do is I just gotta get one.
cause I just gotta get up high enough,
then get one on this so just, woo gentle,
like a baby.
okay, so I'm up.
Is there aaanything up there, nooo?
"Why not!?" says the cat,
nah, there's nothing up there, I just saw.
There's nothing. It's all a red herring
There was no purpose to any of that I wasted my
goddamn time and I can't get in that
goddamn room ahhh boy
ok so...so now I've gotten another puzzle and
I don't know how to solve it. Oh, wait
Maybe I should look here...Oh, maybe I can- maybe I can use this to
grab that thing
no that's no, any of this? Could I grab
any? so this gate is pretty much locked
down
There might be a way around eventually.. What's in here?
whoa, oh, OH! hello?
OH! Well that's good.
I have a keyCARD?!
I have a key card but I don't know where
a key card goes.
Have I seen a key card hole?
I don't know if I've seen the key card slot anywhere...
I mean now would be a good time
to explore because there's a lot of
different places around here... that I could get to-
yeah still doesn't work
oh there it goes. yeap, that didn't do
nothin'! that did nothin'! that did a
whole lot of nothin'!
Oh! I gotta do it twice because that's
perfectly logical!
Ok so somewhere-- hello, hi, ok, goodbye!
Thank you for being an asshole. Alright, so
somewhere in this house there's a key
card and I'm gonna find it!
Hey! I see your buttocks! Don't worry I'll
fix him eventually it's not too fair to
be playing with him like that so I
am gonna get him back into normal order but
I'm gonna find what I need first and
then I'm gonna do it because I'm a fair
understanding gentleman.
hUH!
nope that didn't make it I've got the
wimpiest arms in the world. hee-deh! wow, ok
Nice spin, but no effect. buh-ski! Ooh, It did break!
Okay, that is interesting.
Oh, this one too. ha-bu-ski!
It broke...Is there s-
Oh..what the fuck is that..? What the fuck is that??
I didn't see any big spinning dildo
outside of his house before! Alright but I
can get up there
I know- I know I can get up there. I've
done it before. I don't know if I need
this key anymore, but I'm gonna do it
just in case.
yaHAHAH woah, did it first try but let's see
if I can do this. First try!
I don't need to sprint! YES! OK! There's
something out here! There's a big
spinning dildo! that's cutting- Why I don't
know what the fuck that is. Is that even
supposed to be there? Alright, so there's
something here.. [GASPS]
What is this..? Oh, the gate clipped through the
ceiling here. I don't think I'm supposed
to see this!
oh I don't know why I'm here!
I don't think- oh where does- oh, that does!
that does lead somewhere! [GASPS]
the lAAAAdder! a ladder, oh there's a ladder up
there so I-I know I can get up
oh hello? oh.. ooh well I don't trust myself on
this one haya! ahhh!
ah, fucking fucking.. haaa! fucking oh god oh
god I hate jumping puzzles
oh I hate it
EH! AH! AAAAAAAAAAAAA!
*whimpering* mmmmmm
mmmmmmMMMMMMMMMM
okay i don't- i might- oh..that's gonna
be a tight one. ooh..might be able to ..uahhhhh! yes!
get the fuck out my way!!
can I get up there? Is it a matter of
just grabbing onto it?!
please tell me it's just a matter of touching it.
Hap! Ohhh, wellll~, ooooh, what are- oh fuck what are you?
Open!
yes! okay, whew, I don't know where I am... but
I'm up high! I'm up high baby, I'm up high!!
ok I'm not a pie but I'm up high. what the-
fuck is that
hang on. wait let me- let me just drop
this, oh fuck. I can't see a goddamn thing
okay um..Is there anything that I could what's t-
let me just see- okay I can't get through
here, but there's something here! there's
a vault in there. Ooh. That's weird looking.
That's uh- a little disconcerting! whatever the
hell's in there! woah, some sort of fluid, maybe.
okay but I gotta get this out of
the way. so, let me just drop this for a second.
I can see it at least where it is
throw that outta the way... pick this back up
again and open this
where does this go? now, where the hell
are we now?
woo oh I don't think I supposed to see
this either!
I think maybe this should- oh, shit.. oh, no..
I think I maybe have reached a new level of not-supposed
-to-be-hereness. oh I could jump on the
tracks but that might be a bad thing
because it was hard enough to get up
here as it is
let me see if there's absolutely
anything else here and then I'll think
about it yep there's nothing else here
and I can't get through this door
whatever this Bikini Bottom-esque
looking fucking door is... I have no
fucking idea what that is
I could jump onto the tracks, that is a
thing I could do- I may fall through 'em
ehh, nope i'm on them!
I'm on them. I'm on them I am upon them
"Railroad closed!" maybe that's for the best
but is there-
ooh! That's a tight jump. That's a tight
jump... but I can make that
[TARZAN-LIKE SCREAM]
yeeeEEAAAH BABY! Oh it's locked well ...Wait is it-
Wait is it locked? is it locked?
something weird's about this door if I
magnet it? ehh- nope. something very strange is
going on with this door here! Is there
anything on the other side of that
can I see?
whoa, the fuck is that~...?
oh my god, that is a QR code! That is a
fucking QR code I do not know what that
QR code does but I'm about to find out! Ima read it.
come on read that! Oh come on you can
read that! Maybe it's half of a QR code.
That might be half of a QR code.. ooh shit
fuck where did it go
god dammit ay-yayay.. It might be just half of
a QR code and there's another half
somewhere here so I'm gonna take a
picture of this just because I can
ok so I've got half a QR code. Half.
Half of a QR code doesn't really help me a
whole lot, but I've got it!
I don't know what it means but I have it
so the last thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna try to do this goddamn jumping
puzzle again because if I can figure it
out then I should be ok but it-it's just
annoying because number one I hate
jumping puzzles
whoop!
it's this-it's this one pillar that's in
the way here fucking-noOOOO!!! god fucking
dammit! You fucking--could you stop
throwing jars of horse semen!? Jesus
Christ why do you have so much of that
shit?! So, is there... is there or is there not
another half of a QR code somewhere in
this house?
That's what would make the most sense to  me.
There must be another QR code
somewhere hidden in his house and the
developers know that there's a little
bug that you can look through things but
I dooOOon't knOOow-
fuck--ok well that at least got me back
here whoa, whoa, whoa hah hah ok
where the fuck else do I go?
well that didn't help me much maybe over
this thing? No. Hup! Ooh boy
careful careful careful... Where do I go?
That is a good question
I don't fucking know eeh, oh shit fucking uAHHHHH!! FUCK!
Oh-where am I now? Where am I now?! Whoa
I'm somewhere new
OKAY! I'll take it-oh this just loops back
Okay that just looped back. Ok so anyway
that's all the time I got for this
episode here I've made some good
progress but I've also made some
mistakes! I solved the jumping puzzle but
then I jumped in the wrong place
so uhhh, let me try it one more time. Let me
try to go up there one more time, and I
know, I know... I'm still using him being
stuck in the wall to my advantage, but wouldn't
you guys too? Eeeeeeeeh
boink ok uhaAAAH!! fuck off! fahiyai! Ok--done-done
Fuck you! Alright, it didn't want me to
do it, so I'm not gonna do it! So... I bet
the other QR code maybe is up that way
but I'll get that maybe in the next video
so we'll see.. I have no idea, but either
way, THANK YOU EVERYBODY so much for
watching! Let me know what you thought
down in the comments below and what other
secrets I can explore. So thanks again
and as always, I will see you.. IN THE NEXT VIDEO!
bah-bye!!!